p à la parole et à monsieur pierre
lequiller monsieur le premier ministre
élection après élection les français
sanctionne françois hollande il le
sanctionne pas ce qu'il leur manque
depuis quatre ans sur l'inversion de la
courbe du chômage et parce que sur les
réformes structurelles il biaise il
louvoie il rétropédale sans cesse nos
partenaires européens ont le même
sentiment
il le remet en année après année sur le
déficit budgétaire en 2012 il avait
promis 3% pour 2013
promesse même pas tenu en 2016 et
sûrement pas en 2017 d'après la
commission européenne qui épingle la
france
elles dénoncent l'insuffisance des
réformes structurelles les problèmes de
compétitivité
le fort endettement public et un taux de
chômage élevé la france s'expose
désormais à l'ouverture possible d'une
procédure d'infraction
elle fait partie des trois plus mauvais
élèves de la zone euro pour toute
réponse françois hollande rejette d'un
revers de main les critiques notamment
celles émises par deux de ses amis
le commissaire pierre moscovici et le
président de la cour des comptes didier
migaud devant la hausse brutale de
température il préfère casser le
thermomètre vih et les remèdes la
situation économique de la france
la panne du couple franco-allemand
illustré par vos leçons données à la
chancelière sur le sol allemand
en plus en pleine campagne électorale
monsieur le premier ministre
affaiblissent l'influencent de la france
pourtant il faut plus que jamais relancé
l'europe autour de la zone euro et
renforcer les politiques communes il
faudra à françois hollande une vision
européenne qui manque cruellement depuis
2012 du jamais vu depuis le début de la
vème république
alors dans le cadre du semestre européen
quel programme de réformes structurelles
comptez vous présenter pour redresser la
france et récupéré le crédit perdu
auprès de nos partenaires européens à
paroles est à monsieur harlem désir
secrétaire d'état chargé des affaires
européennes
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
pierre lequiller oui la france se
réforme
oui la france respecte ses engagements
européens
oui monsieur le député le déficit de la
france baisse il était de 5,1 pour cent
en 2011 il sera de moins de 3 8% cette
année et l'année prochaine et nous
allons respecter nos engagements
européens
oui la france met en oeuvre des réformes
comme tous les pays de l'union
européenne war vous allez bientôt
pouvoir examiner une réforme sur le
marché du travail qui est issu de la ciu
chaussures avec ses partenaires calme en
chantant c'est à la fois la négociation
collective la sécurité pour les salariés
la prévisibilité pour les employeurs
d'autres pays ont fait ces réformes
depuis déjà bien longtemps
vous mentionnez l'allemagne il y a dix
ans l'allemagne faisait des réformes
c'étaient les réformes hartz elle
n'était pas faite en france elles sont
faites maintenant en france oui nous
faisons des réformes
quand nous faisons la réforme des
collectivités territoriales et monsieur
le député je voudrais vous inviter dans
ce moment où en effet nous avons besoin
que l'europe fonctionne qu elle réponde
aux urgences aux crises la crise des
réfugiés
la crise du terrorisme la nécessité
d'une politique extérieure et de défense
commune plus fort et pondre à
l'instabilité à ses frontières que vous
ne contribuerez pas un french bashing
qui n'est plus de saison
il ne l'est plus en europe parce que
c'est la france et l'allemagne qui en
sort le négocie pour la paix en ukraine
entre l'ukraine et la syrie ça s'appelle
le format normandie parce que la
première réunion a eu lieu en france à
l'initiative du président de la
république oui c'est la france qui
négocient pour la paix en syrie oui
c'est la france qui avec le ministre de
la défense cherche une solution à la
crise en libye
soyez fiers et
soutenez le rôle de la france pour
relancer l'europe avec l'allemagne et
répondre aux urgences de l'actualité
européenne
merci monsieur